twenty-one military students from Saudi
Arabia were removed from the u.s. last
night over alleged social media links
with the extremist material in child
pornography the FBI says they made the
discoveries while investigating the
December six Pensacola Naval Air Station
shooting when a Saudi cadet killed three
US sailors there CBS News senior
investigative correspondent Catherine
Herridge was at yesterday's news
conference and joins us now with more on
this story captain good morning to you
what else are investigators telling you
well thank you Galen good morning the
Attorney General called the shooting an
act of terror and based on the evidence
so far the FBI said the shooter appeared
to act alone but investigators still
have questions and can't access his two
iPhones setting up a clash between the
FBI and Apple this was an act of
terrorism Attorney General Bill Barr
revealed Saudi Air Force officer
mohammed al sham rani was motivated by
jihadist ideology he also posted other
anti-american anti Israeli and jihadi
messages on social media including two
hours before his attack Barr said the 21
year old Saudi national posted on
September 11th that quote the countdown
has begun and visited New York City's
9/11 memorial just days before the
attack so far the FBI investigation
indicates that the shooter acted alone
when investigators also want apples help
unlocking two iPhones recovered at the
scene one in the gunman's car and one
near his body that he had deliberately
shot it is very important for us to know
with whom and about what the shooter was
communicating in a statement Apple
disagreed with the Attorney General's
claim the company hasn't been helpful
saying its responses to the FBI's
requests have been timely thorough and
ongoing but Apple also hinted it won't
unlock the FBI's access to the encrypted
iPhones saying there's no such thing as
a backdoor just for the good guys over
the course of the investigation the FBI
separately found 17 Saudi canet
social-media contained jihadist or
anti-american content individuals in
that group and others also had some kind
of con
tact with child pornography in a
statement the Saudi embassy said the
cadets demonstrated conduct unbecoming
of an officer the US military trains
foreign nationals to build partnerships
including more than 800 Saudis going
forward the Pentagon said it will do a
deeper dive on the applicants Anthony
Catherine thank you
you